So you want to know my secret
neahehehe
I am an epic gamer.
That's right.
Hate it or like it
I don't care.
My K/D is at least one.
I play all the coolest games
None of that candy crush stuff like fortnite
ehehehhe
Epic gamer
We gamers will rise because we are the most oppressed group on the Internet. No one takes us seriously
Well, I say it's enough we've dealt with enough abuse and bashing by the media saying that gaming is a mental
disorder I think NO! join me fellow gamers and together
We will rise
Let's review some other gamers to perhaps
Inspire you that's right everybody. It doesn't matter where you're from as long as you eat sleep Fortnite
Repeat you're in huh? Don't piss me off
I'm close to leveling up and you look like just enough
Experience he's gonna smash you. Have you ever seen anyone wearing these shirts? I wanted to buy one So badly
I don't understand why I'm not gonna spend money on something ironic to wear that's just PEWDIEPIE. We must protect
Veronica from chad but society is holding us back. Damn you society
The thing about gamers is that we're not just good with our thumbs
We're also good with our minds. There is people in the world. It really makes you think
Truly makes you think it's almost like we live in a society
Don't f with the Skyrim player, we will suck your dick. Okay, this is *epic*
Chad is the main character of fortnite Season 5 stupid
attractive big bulge alpha male
WTF epic games this is not epic at all. This is a blatant insult to us gamers
We are the biggest supporters of fortnight not Chad and we will rise up
That's right. Pride months is over
Boo-hoo-hoo. It's time for gamer month leave a like on this video
If you're an epic gamer right now just like me and Sonic of course
LGBTQ eg epic gamer why don't we get recognized like we deserve F gamers?
What did you say an F gaming? I said fu gamer big mistake new?
Wait, no, please don't put you eat. That's right everybody
Sometimes we go savage mode and we pone
opression then and
Oppression now, this is an ocean
This is a no gaming zone, you are not allowed to play games in this library
Wait Logan Paul is a gamer
Logan Paul gets starring law-and-order SVU in
2015 as an angry gamer who starts a campaign on harassment against a female of game developer
Logan Logan together we will rise I
Didn't know I didn't know I swear I didn't know I didn't know gamer headset
It's on
Knuckles. Yeah, they're cracked feeding up. Oh
Yeah ace epic gamer time good evening. Ladies and gentlemen
I'm
But more importantly Veronica you still have yet to call me back
I'm just gonna
You have 24 hours to make that call and
I will unleash the full might of a gamer army upon you
Gamer fear not Veronica, I'll save you I'm so happy I get to see my chad again
We live in a society. We're living our society guys. The meme is back. Apparently, it's not a meme
It's actually the fact we are living in a society and don't take it just from me
Take it from woke number 5000 epic gamer Kanye West. We live in a society. He just knows guys
I'm not a player. I'm a gamer because players gets chicks
What I get is arrested for possession of child
Okay, this is not epic who changed this gamers rise me me a gamer
Society this meme was made by Bayne Squad
society
Veronica, why does Chad get Veronica? Does Veronica
know my KD is way higher? Does Veronica not know that any time a girl boys enters in the videogame
I always say wow a girl in a video game
You know, I want you to know that I'm actually exclusive with another girl named Veronica
So don't expect me to do anything special for you like I would do for my gf
Veronica like giving our health potions like taking 10 damage for her. Okay, that is just for Veronica
Random girl online. I don't care about you. All right
I have a lot of line lists of girls that I could go with. All right, but my heart belongs to Veronica
All right
Just want to make that clear one time that was in a video game and a girl joined and my teammate said Wow
Are you playing in the kitchen and I say: dude, Brad, that is not epic. girls are gamers, too
Girls are gamers to say it with me girls are gamers, too
Girls are gamers too gamers will rise up together
Epic gamer
epic gamer
number one
Hate you don't care. You're stupid
Whatever. You're ugly. Say what?
You're ugly. Well, we so are you gaming is bullshit.
Now you take that back the only way to make me study even then as an epic gamer
I would still be able to play on I don't care my passion for gaming outgrows any pain any suffering
gaming for life
gaming forever
gaming for the universe
Gamers are not really oppressed says society. What did you say? *snap*
This is going in my cringe compilation and I don't even care what you have to say about it. Do you still
Underestimate the power of a gamer? You can call me a loser in real life any day but in this society
You're the loser, but in my epic gaming world I'm slaying
Dwarven mages I'm slaying dwarma gnomes left and right. Do you know how many girlfriends I have online? They killed Jesus
because he was a gamer but that's why he rose up and we must follow him a
gamer
feminism
Marxism
Not being
Are they making fun of
veterans gets
PTSD but us gamers we get
WASD a you think you had it tough and numb try go to molten core with only four
Healers. Okay grandpa. I don't care about your Vietnam stories
Have you ever tried going to molten core with only four healers? I don't care
You may think I'm a loser in real life but in the gaming world
You're the loser
Together us gamers are strong for too long. We have been oppressed by all these groups
Everyone is against us but we are the toughest most hard-working most vigilant
most
Powerful group on the Internet if we all together
Will rise up we can defeat anything we can take over the world
We can create the gaming utopia that we all wanted to live with cars are not cars their game ours
Houses are not houses. Their gaming studios roads are not roads
their candy crush displays
Imagine it just think about how good things could really be
Think about how bad we are now because we haven't raisin up yet the more we wait
The harder it will get but now is the time for gamers to rise
together
Leave a like to show that you support
This cause yeah
Tea and oh
I have an epic kill streak. Where do you work at? a gamestop Emma Watson?
It's sad that we live in a society Emma Watson epic gamer confirmed